[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
将棋大好き弾い余談です皆さん将棋で遊んだことありますでしょうか
扇田は相手の番自分の番を交互につれたりして自分の番ごとに一回だけ
コマを動かせるして交互に駒を動かして相手どこが起こって行き最終的に桜を賞をとっ
たものの勝利と
昔からあるホテも戦略的な
[音楽]
なんだかでしょういってでしょう議員はいろんな駒の種類がありますへい
銀金か車校舎テーマ各地車
いろんな子はがあってそれぞれ動きが違うんです例えば歩兵だったら前にしかウケない
シーンだったら斜め下意外な
受け便だったら横と後ろ受けなは2個前の隣に動ける車貨車はもうまっすぐにしかいけ
ませんの端
油断が生ちょっとだけ将棋やったことがあるんですけどもあまりの湯浅あまりの頭の悪
さに挫折しまして大まかなルールスがちょっとわからないんですけども将棋の駒の中で
もう
初心者にでもわかるこれマジで強いなっているのが2個あるんですよ
こちら者と核ですどう強いかというと飛車は8縦横であれば無限にすることができる
ってか加え七海であればどこでももう15むずになるどこでも進めますそこで私は思い
ました
この2つがもう僕の中でやの最強なんですよ明らかにパワーが違うであればこの2つ私
てどっちが強いでしょうか g 4だこれどっちが違う調べるためにわざわざの将棋の
駒をつくっている山の中職人さんに連絡して作って頂きました
ご覧ください
[音楽]
はい全部書くそして
[拍手]
医者だけと価格だけとかこのコマだけで売ってるのはなくて将棋の駒作っている職人
さんとこに行ったら書くと1社だけに10個集めてくれて
合わせていただけました本当にありがとうございますコマたくさんってくれたおばあ
ちゃんは前代未聞だと何を考えているのかわからんと言われました
アースというレアな80断交がやってみたいのか飛車と角ドッグ
松阪今日明らかにしてみようと思います王将を以外のすべてのコマを全部書く
大全部自社で戦ってみようと思いますでしょう切ってめっちゃくちゃプレイヤースキル
に依存するものなので僕みたいな馬鹿な初心者とは彼の初心者の広範囲を準備しており
ますので刃が大バカ者体格でどっちで釣るのか色々検証して記者の方が強ければいい
したぜ葛飾区のが強ければ書くのが絶対勝つ踊れるバカレベル同じくらいなんで
そこで戦ってみようと思います探して記者と関係どっちがてるのか
g 4曲実況は私枝が務めさせていただきますよろしくお願い致しますよろしくお願い
致します
今回は端はじめ魚弾大栄女流二段
トマトのへた自身の試合でございますこの試合全て各たいすべて1社多い階すべて各
堆肥舎になっております
奪った相手の駒はもちろん使いません各飲みたい日者のみの試合でございます
果敢に攻めるはトマト技師飛車をどんどんと前に出して相手の角を奪っていきます
各はとても強い斜めに動く作戦ができると
ただ弱点としては大変分かりづらい
そして
飛車のチーム死者は名前がかっこいい
をさっそう大手が出ました各で大大大狙っていきます
どうてるか
飛車は縦横床にでも動きますなるほど
をてってそのタイミングで使うんですね食べるとき大手って良いですか
桜が取れる時に被って取れませんわかりました車
いいましたんですか mc とトマトのへた選手大手のいうタイミングがわからなかっ
たみたいでございますすぐ者で大手を交わしていく試合が進んで行きません
パッと見トマト酢自身の方が優勢にみえますねー
本当の角でまた大手を取りに行くはずで4弾
ホットパッドまた者で取られる
やはり縦横どこでも動けるが強いまた大手ですねはいすぐ取られてしまいます
やはり者の機動性が優れているせいか
各はちょっと動きづらそうですねー
さあここで覆ってトマト獅子王てです
どうするここは頭が下がるかだが周りを一緒に囲まれていますねー
ポッドで過度の籠打って f たナビ大手
顔が曇る弾い4弾
トマトんちょ流二段も
これは決まったという顔
さあどうなる
まいりましたはいまずは1本ね死者の価値でございますさあ
に曲名です次はお互いのコマこのが足りてないみたいですね
飛車と角の場所になかったですねしっかりしていただきたいところですね
パティがうちょっと内側ティショットまーぬーします
次は逆にはず四段がすべて1社と窓の下手女流二段がすべて各の対局になります
傘に攻めればトマト女流二段
ちょっと国交は
桜の前に者を
起きましたねまあに二右者に書くという概念がないのでどんどんを重ねていってもいい
ですね
果敢に攻めていきますがやはり社の自動力に曲げてしまいますか長谷部取られてしまい
ます
相手の言ってにすぐ対応できますね
8人用なんです
斜めに動くねちょっと分かりづらそうですねー
考えるとマット諸流二段
攻めるが
どうする
まっすぐで取りに行く8十分
なかなかいい正午しているように見えますが
あ試合方を動くかおっと気づいたらを盤面に角が1個
オーガ1個そしては取られて大滝になってしまいました
もう
打つ手がないのか多い
ただ1持った大ただ一人たいオート久が
ごっこ
あとは詰め寄るだけですはず冗談だかあげる男で記者を取れがそれはまだのように
しっかりとおおぉ
詰め寄る飛車の周南
大手です
に行けばはないように見えますが
さすがに一車4台に囲まれるのは苦しいのじゃねえ所がまいりましたさあ対局終了です
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ